il existe depuis des siècles et
millénaires ils sont là tapi dans
l'ombre ils croupissent au fond de nos
histoires et de nominal qui sont enfuis
dans nos cauchemars
jusqu'au jour où les monstres seront les
maîtres du destin de chacun d'entre eux
soit les fans de monstres du canada des
états-unis de défaut les arts hindle
robert maillet kevin nash chimie art
mordin jason brawn et cyclope la momie
les lits vampire son imam sorcière
maudite le du tri la gloire ou francs
huit monstres meurtrier venus des quatre
coins du monde convoquée sur le ring
pour couronner le tout puissant
destructeur qui ait jamais été
par al hakim combat des plus grands
ports et doit en profiter vous balancer
tout ce qu'il a sur ce gros flop et
monster je vous aurais prévenu tous ceux
qui regarderont le monster ball
repartiront dissidents des housses
mortuaires